لكن بعد الدبابات على تقتراحات غربيه
بمساعدتكاف بذخائر عنقوديه وتزويدها
بطائرات افسته عشر شركه لوكد مارتن اعلنت
استعدادها لتلبيه الطلب على طائراتها من
طراز اف 16 بينما اقترحت دوله اوروبيه
ارسل ذخائر عنقوديه الى اوكرانيا
لمساعدتها في ساحه المعركه دعونا مشاهدينا
الان نتعرف الى ذخائر العنقوديه و طائرات
الحربيه اف 16 سابدا مع ذخائر العنقوديه
هي اسلحه تتكون من حاويه تفتح في الهواء
وتنثر اعدادا كبيرا من القنابل الصغيره او
الذخائر الصغيره المتفجره كما يمكن القاء
ذخائر العنقوديه عن طريق الطائرات او
المدفعيه او الغذاء هذا النوع من ذائر
استخدم للمره الاولى في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ونسبه كبيره من الذخائر العنقوديا
المخزنه في الوقت الحالي صممت للاستخدام
في البارده في المناسبه مشاهدينا هذا
النوع من القنابل محرم دوليا اما طائره
افسته عشر الامريكيه تنتمي الى الجيل
الرابع من المقاتلات الحربيه وتعد من اهم
الطائرات الحربيه المقاتله خفيفه الوزن
سرعه الطائره تصل عند اقصى ارتفاع لها الى
اكثر من 2400 كيلو متر بالساعه اما سرعتها
على مستوى سطح البحر تصل الى اكثر من 1400
كيلو متر
كذلك يصل متوسط عدد ساعات الطيران للطائره
الواحده خلال عمرها الافتراضي الى حوالي
اثنى عشر الف ساعه الطيران فقط تقريبا
يمتلك هذا النوع من الطائرات قدرات وميزات
اعداد اهمها قدرتها على اصابه الهدف بكل
دقه سواء في البحر او الجو بالاضافه الى
قدرتها على التعبئه الوقود اثناء الطيران
وقدرتها على الطيران لمسافات بعيده وفي اي
ظروف جويه